tomorrow din David when Millennials are
in charge what will happen I have one
word that connects to my interest in
seeing how Millennials will run the
world and that word is and this might be
a shock to many people the word is
socialism and the reason that the word
is socialism is not because I expect our
Western capitalist societies to become
socialistic utopia's or dystopias
depending on your perspective but
because we see that now current
Millennials are holding one of the most
favorable views to socialist ideas that
we've seen in a very very long time
and when it is those same Millennials
that are running more and more of the
major corporations right not just like
Facebook but more and more of major
corporations running schools in politics
I think that it would be very very
interesting to observe again not an
elimination of capitalism but do we move
in the direction of a more Scandinavian
style capitalism in a country like the
United States by virtue of having
empower a generation that is more open
to ideas of the Commons and socialistic
ideas and social welfare programs a
generation that we have seen is less
into owning stuff than they are into
experiences and access to stuff as we
see by technologies like Zipcar and uber
and Airbnb and others I think that the
political sensitivities of the
Millennial Generation are going to be
very interesting in terms of how they
manifest when the millennial generation
is more broadly in power so that that's
the one that I know that there's other
people who talk about like really
specific technology stuff that might or
might not happen as a result of
Millennials being in power or maybe
things about birth rates based on
Millennials particularly on the coasts
waiting longer to have children I think
that those are interesting sort of micro
ideas but the big-picture outlook on the
world of Millennials is something that
I'm most interested in seeing yeah I
mean I think there are a lot of good
things coming up these cryptocurrency
you know renewable energy sources coming
the rule some cool like hipster clothing
stores perhaps really close yessir
clothing stores restaurant chain vegan
yeah I don't know that hipster clothing
stores are high on my list for what I'm
gonna be following closely as
Millennials take control but I think
that the food habits also will be an
interesting one actually that is one
thing I did miss which is more of a
sensitivity to the idea that as much as
I may or may not like meat the sort of
undeniable reality of the impact of high
meat diets and I'm hoping we continue to
move in the direction of really the
Mediterranean diet which is time and
again seen been seen as one that is way
better for the environment and seems to
also correlate if not cause some of the
longest living communities around the
world so yeah diet diet will be an
interesting one as well send me your
thoughts what are you curious about when
Millennials take over we've got a great
bonus show for you today
if you're not a member or a patron the
no bonus show for you that's sad but
it's a reality and in that case we'll be
back on Monday